[Musique]
george groupie captons pierron jean
soyez ou encore psycho ils ont déployé
leurs oeuvres
un peu partout dans le château avec
chacun sa salle attitrée
parmi eux figure une femme claire boris
elle est venue avec son univers son
petit monde de sculpture des personnages
en ciment à qui elle donne vie et
légèreté par les attitudes selon leurs
orientations
il raconte une histoire le décor est
assez important ce qui est bien aussi
c'est le souhait d'avoir un fond neutre
soit effectivement d'être à l'extérieur
et puis avec selon la luminosité aussi
du soleil touche tout va changer
la sculpture soit il va pleuvoir et là
elles vont être prêts foncé après ça
redevient comme ça et une fois que
enfin quand il ya du soleil ça brille ça
enfin voilà les nuages elle change à
chaque fois elle évolue dans la nature
selon la luminosité
j'en sois y est exposé partout dans le
monde
c'est la première fois qu'il vient à
saint jean le blanc il a répondu à
l'appel des copains et découvrent les
lieux avec plaisir je vécus pendant que
ma foi d'office on se sent très bien
très bien les amis tout de suite qui on
va te donner un coup de main à 20 je
pense qu'ils vont mener après donner le
coup d'oeil finale en dix ans mais
pourquoi tu à lui seul la seule feuille
dans le positionnement des toiles il
faut faire attention
à l'étagé sic où nous emmène dans son
univers de voitures de bande dessinée
avec cette année une nouveauté le
travail à l'encré de chine
en général je travaille la peinture à
l'huile sur toile des grands formats des
formats plus petits mais il est souvent
la peinture à l'huile et des petits
formats à l'angle de chine ou à
l'aquarelle sur papier et cette année
j'ai décidé de grandir un peu et de
transposer ma technique sur papier sur
toile pour pouvoir présenter un travail
complètement nouveau l'exposition se
tient jusqu'au 14 avril au château de
saint jean le blanc